you said that a harmless man is not a
good man a good man is a very dangerous
man who has that under voluntary control
how should people become more dangerous
oh
becoming more articulate is definitely i
would say
that's the primary
array of weapons
so i mean physical prowess is something
and it's not nothing that physical
confidence that comes along with that as
well
but the same thing replicated at the
level of the ability to communicate and
to think
that's a
way broader field of of battle and
opportunity
so
this is one thing that isn't taught well
especially to boys
it's more important to teach it to boys
i would say because they're more
skeptical of such of the educational
enterprise in general generally speaking
partly because they're less obedient
partly because they're less agreeable
that's particularly true for
disagreeable boys
and agreeable boys get higher grades
independent of their iq and their and
their academic achievement because
they're easier to deal with
so what do you tell disagreeable boys
there's nothing that makes you more
formidable than verbal competence than
being able to articulate be able to
think to marshal your arguments right
some battlefield metaphor
to get everything in order
get all your information straight
no to marshall your forces
and so i mean that's part of the reason
that rap
artists are so popular especially among
disaffected young men black and white
alike
because they're unbelievably articulate
they have this incredible verbal prowess
it's unbelievably attractive you know
and it's associated with genuine
artistic
and redemptive
activity
often focusing on
something that's approximately the voice
of the
underclass let's say
but a powerful voice right and it's
interesting to see how many young white
guys identify with that
was it aldous huxley that wrote doors of
perception yeah yeah so this is kind of
an equivalent of that right that you
have a experience which many people
struggle to articulate you take the best
of us
the one that has the most precise most
articulate erudite language
you drop them in and you say okay
show us what you've learned
this is the equivalent but for just a
different community a different sort of
life
that maybe you don't have the ability to
describe what it feels like to live
on a council estate in manchester or in
you know the one of the
neighborhoods of brooklyn or whatever it
might be
and then this person can
and it feels like it's your voice yeah
well you still if you're a young man you
still feel alienated from your place as
rightful heir of the proper kingdom i
mean that's an existential truism for
everyone for every particularly for
every young man because he is an
outsider in many ways he's young and
juvenile and not very highly valued and
and then
is is in some sense hurt by the
inadequacies of the current king the
current culture and and it's easily
turned against it because of that and
that's the machinations of the evil
uncle that's the king arthur's story
that's the story of horus
horus and osiris it's an ancient ancient
story it's the story of sauron and um
it's there all the time and
you see in that in rap music in hip-hop
the the all of that alienation being
given an articulated voice in an
artistic sense and that's a good example
of the power of verbal facility and
that's the route to let's say marketing
education to young men it's like you
want to
you want to take your rightful place in
the kingdom it's like get your tongue
straight man get it under control
in the highest possible sense we went to
a comedy club tammy and i and
in uh new york the comedy cellar it's a
great comedy club and the last comic was
an english guy and uh
he was
uh not particularly physically
pre-possessing and he he made a lot of
jokes about that and it was quite funny
and then he divided the audience into
five sections and he asked each section
to toss up a topic just to yellow the
topic
and they were like random topics like
the kennedy assassination and
electric lighting before 1890 those were
two of the topics and the other three
were just as diverse
and then he put on some beats and he did
about an eight minute wrap
with every verse
rhymed
and he tied the whole thing together at
the end and ended at the end of the
music all spontaneously
was unbelievable
and that's logos man that's the
redemptive power of the logos right
there the magic word the sacred word
it's just manifesting itself on stage
this is something very impressive
something about that that does feel
dangerous as well
and not in a
i need to be concerned and this should
be contaminated and walled off but in a
way that you think that person has so
much competence
that it it's flowing out of them and you
almost feel competent by being around
them so you certainly feel confident by
appreciating it
right because it speaks to the part of
you that is capable of appreciating such
things you think wow that's really
something that's really that's an
amazing display that's an amazing thing
to see amazing right
a very interesting word amazing and
you're you're trapped and you're trapped
by the charisma of that and that
charisma that's not nothing that's
that's a signal of something redemptive
occurring that that accounts for
virtually all of the attraction of
hip-hop and rap
it's the articulate articulated voice of
the
struggling
but worthy
underclass i suppose that's a good way
of putting it but those who are
alienated
from their rightful place
and so that verbal prowess is one of the
ways they
struggle up towards the light you know
and and that that's a good example of
that uh
of having that danger under control
because it's a dark genre in many ways
right it's it's a
there's a there's a there's a real
undercurrent an era of violence that
surrounds
that and its culture like the punk
movement in the in
in the uk back in the late 70s same same
sort of thing
but that
that capacity to express that in a
poetic manner
in a compelling manner sid or johnny
rotten was great at that he was so
intense
his he worked with pil afterwards public
in public image limited is that his
public image i think so he has a song
called rise which i used to show my
my clients all the time when i was
starting uh
assertiveness training with them i'd put
on
johnny rotten's
rise and the line in there is anger is
an energy and he's got these
unbelievably intense eyes anger is an
energy you bet and john lyden man he
could channel that like almost no one
i've ever seen he'd get that anger built
up inside him and then it was completely
under control and he expressed it in his
music and he's absolutely captivating
unbelievably charismatic and i really
liked his music that raw anger in the
music that but it was
it was in the bloody music wasn't it
it wasn't some random riot
you know
he transmuted that into something you
know you can argue about the poetic
merits of um
of punk rock although i don't think you
should i mean uh i did it my way sid
vicious version of i did it my way my
god that's a work of genius that it's so
it's so brilliantly satirical
what someone's doing is they're refining
it they're distilling it down and then
they're directing it so i went to a
powerlifting competition a couple of
years ago there's this one guy there
lifting he holds a bunch of records in
the squat
and he's a normal working-class guy from
a normal working-class town on the
outskirts of newcastle and watching that
man warm up
is something else he's got a sacred
playlist he never listens to the songs
apart from when he's about to step on to
the lifting platform
he's got these headphones on and he's
just walking up and down in the same way
that you'd see a bull
ready ready to go out ready to go and
chase something and he steps out on
stage
and the hares stand up on the back of
your neck you're watching this guy
channel
fury that's the god of war that's mars
yeah he's in touch with that
unbelievable and words man you go to war
with words
and you think that's what young men
should be taught
there we go
bit of fury
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you